bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors la situation
sanitaire inquiète de nombreux
scientifiques et cette étude comme corps
je veux le dire
selon laquelle le risque de transmission
est plus fort en crèche ou maternelle au
collège et au lycée qu'en première on l
ignore si tu es pourtant on aura bien
une rentrée des classes de mort comment
interprétez vous cette décision du
gouvernement c'est tout bêtement une
obstination de monsieur blanc caire a
continué à mentir
il est mon depuis des mois sur la
contamination la contagiosité des jeunes
des enfants mais aussi des plus jeunes
les autres en des ados et pourtant ils
sont contagieux hirson contaminants ils
peuvent en mourir ils peuvent rarement
c'est sûr mais ils peuvent avoir des cas
graves les cas graves s'accélère au
royaume uni et en france
rien n'est fait on a un ministre qui est
totalement sourd à tous nos appels
depuis le mois de juin nous demandons à
ce que le les écoles et collèges des
lycées se fasse en 2000 groupe pour
éviter justement cette contagion pour
éviter la deuxième vague n'avons jamais
été entendue résultat on est dedans
la troisième vague et là elle arrive en
fait c'est bien la pologne même le
prolonge la deuxième vague puisque rien
n'a été fait de sérieux en france on est
le seul pays quasiment en europe a
continué à avoir les écoles ouvertes à
35 40 par classe sans aucune
distanciation social ça je veux vraiment
que les gens entendent il n'y a aucune
distanciation sociale à l'école les
enseignants les personnels d'éducation
les ash et autres sont en danger
il peut attraper le coc vide à cause du
travail nous n'avons même pas une prime
par ailleurs rapport à cette situation
nous n'avons eu aucune augmentation avec
ce grenelle 1 din qui a eu lieu à 70%
des profs sont pas augmentés on est
vraiment méprisés et cette situation
continue à être très préoccupante locaux
vides va continuer à circuler
les profs sont toujours sacrifié et les
élèves sont en danger actuellement
quelles sont les mesures les restes
barrière la reine le sanitaire qui sont
mises en place dans les écoles pour
limiter la propagation du virus
ah bah comme depuis septembre en gros on
a tous des masques toute la journée
concours donc les élèves ont du mal par
moments et on peut tout à fait les
comprendre je veux dire je suis le
premier à le comprendre
nous mêmes on a du mal parlé toute la
journée 1 mais vraiment tout le temps
dans un masque c'est difficile donc on
est faite s'il y en a la gorge sèche ça
fatigue beaucoup plus et puis c'est tout
et on est 35 collés les uns aux autres
moi je peux vous le dire mon élève le
plus proche il a 60 cm de mon visage il
a 60 centimètres de son voisin il a 60
cm de ceux derrière il n'y a aucune
distanciation social gestes barrière se
laver les mains de temps en temps les
salles sont lavés une à deux fois par
jour ça ne suffit pas il faudrait
qu'elle soit lavé après chaque passage
de main d'un élève
si on voulait être j'entends comme à
l'hôpital l'école ne doit pas être un
hôpital heureusement mais en tout cas
les rien n'est fait il n'y a aucun
protocole sérieux et solide
l'école le collège le lycée de france
sur les endroits les moins sécurisée
possible
il n'y a pas d'endroit où il y à un
protocole moins strict que l'école
nicolas beer merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant et membre des skis le rouge
merci à vous d'avoir leur directs sur
arte france